Jim! Come on, Jim!
Just stay low!
The coast seems to be clear, Jim
Our uncle sneaky Jim would be really proud of us.
It's a wonderland of evidence in here!
Safari hunt gone wrong,
Colonel, Colonel, Colonel, Colonel- Ooh!
A picture!
We can only surmise that the evidence here portrays the portrayal of the death of whoever the hell died
in this manor.
Ah, See- R! I wonder what 'R' did to produce that much disdain
Who could've done this?
Who could've made this?
Ah. Now I have imprinted this all in my brain
I can recreate this to the best of my ability the body may be gone
But we have a dummy to reenact my assumption stands as thus
Dummy Jim here, will portray the murdered beloved
AUGHHH
Dead from a fall maybe, or strangled, by his own cord
Or he was thrown into the bathtub and then stomped on, 'till his shins splintered!
Or mayhaps, a lover's embrace squoozed too deeply
In his orgasmic delight, did perish thusly! UH! And then, when he was trying to flee from
Whoever the murderer was,
Mayhaps, he took a loping gait to try to dissuage the attacker!
And that, OH No,
Dead
But, we can't stay here long, (smooch) we have to keep moving, stay low!
Sneaky Jim!
Sneaky Jim!!
Come with me!
Run, run!
Save yourself (smooch)
GO!
Go!